yes indeed garrett cole towing the slab
in the boogie down here tonight this
will be his 11th start
coming off of his best one of the year
he was dominant in that seven inning
complete game two hitter with one walk
and nine strikeouts against baltimore in
that last outing cut
strikes out on three straight and he'll
be ready to deal 2-2 to buchet that one
is ripped to left field really crushed
but a nice running play by clint frazier
tracked that down beautifully made it
look easy and that will bring up
left-handed travis shaw and the bits
caught on a missed and a great change by
cole
so two strikeouts and a one two three
so here is dj
lemayo swung on and hit in the air to
right that ball is high it is far it is
gone
into the right field seats he's done it
again
david john makes long gone he leads off
the game with a home run
he is one flat out terrific player and
the yankees take a one-nothing lead and
here is aaron judge so judge has played
one game since august 11th out with a
strained right calf swing and a miss
judge down on strikes it could be a
milestone night for garrett if he gets
the win in this one it'll be his 100th
career win he comes into the game at 99
and 55. swing and a miss
one away complete attack mode right now
so there's a bass runner with two outs
sky three is called blister to fastball
strikeout number five for cole a hot
shot from wade uh here is higashiyoka
higgy swings and wallops wanted deep
center back goes greyjack on the track
he's at the wall she's gone
higushi oka
the home run
and getting higgy with it he hits a
two-run home run and the yankees take a
three-nothing lead oh that that fence
just erupted when he did that well we go
to the the bottom of the fourth inning
and here's clint frazier high fly ball
deep left gorielle kearns looks
see ya a long home run for frasier the
yankees third blast of the night and
it's four nothing bombers if you'll
watch him no lower half just nothing but
hands
quick batten
and just absolutely smokes it to left
field dj has homer didn't walk swung on
and hit in the air to deep right that
ball is high it is far it is gone
he has done it again
dj
david john makes long gun
he hits his second home run of the game
a two-run home run and the yankees have
given garrett cole a six-nothing lead
one base runner for the blue jays the
walk to the number nine hitter danny
jansen with two outs in the third two
outs here in the fifth swinging a pop-up
shallow in center weighed underneath it
calling for it five no hit innings worth
of work for garrett coleman and two down
here is clint frazier line drive a base
hit to center for you
hicks rounds third he's coming home
and the throw is way wide so an rbi
single for frazier and it's seven
nothing ends
with a seven nothing lead over the blue
jays and garrett cole returns to the
hill without allowing a hit jonathan vr
swings at the first pitch and he rips it
down the right field line base hit
skipping all the way into the corner and
he's got the blue jays first hit of the
night and runners around the corners
with one out here in the sixth for
toronto and he spiked the fastball way
out in front of the plate here comes vr
the throwback by higashiyoka is late and
the blue jays have their first run of
the night now here is higashioka who has
his two run home run and fly to left
swung on and hit in the air to left
field that ball is high it is far it is
gone
he's in his second home run of the night
agashiyoka
the home run stroka
and getting iggy with it
a homer still left and the yankees take
an 8-1 lead
and that is their fifth homer of the
night
eleven and two nights against toronto
pitcher here is luke voight chew on two
out and the pitch is swung on a high fly
to left guriel back he's on the track
that ball is gone
his 19th of the year a three-run shot it
is 11-1 yankees
owen two on vr sky three isn't that
something he gave up two hits and then
struck out the side a runner at first
two men out higashiyoka is a right-hand
hitter high fly ball by higashiyoka deep
to right field oh yes higgy does it
three times another home run for
higashiyoka and it's 13-1 yankees
and the blue jays are down to their
final out
panic gives this one a ride to right
field
and joe panic has just hit his first
home run of the season
well this should do it kratz fields
flips to nelson and they get him and
that will do it
here at the stadium as the yankees
win for the second straight night
against the blue jays